InGen's origins, Rexy's legacy, and an oddly
high number of reconciling couples.
We're digging deep to unearth the finer points
of the entire "Jurassic Park" franchise.
"How'd you do this?"
"I'll show you."
Sixty-five million years ago, the late Cretaceous
Period met the Paleogene Period.
This marked the sudden mass extinction of
three-quarters of the animals and plants on
earth — including all dinosaurs.
In a prologue for "Jurassic World: Dominion"
that was cut from the final version, viewers
are introduced to a host of dinosaurs like
the dreadnoughtus and Moros intrepidus — both
of which had been previously unseen in the
franchise.
At the end of the prologue, the last dinosaur
to be introduced is the giganotosaurus, the
largest apex predator of all time, and it
quickly asserts its dominance over a Tyrannosaurus rex.
This scene isn't only significant because
a genetically engineered version of the giganotosaurus
returns to reclaim that title later on in
the film, though.
It also links back to the scene in the first
"Jurassic Park" film, when Alan, Ellie, and
Ian watch a short film about a mosquito getting
encased in amber and fossilized after drinking
the blood of a dinosaur.
"Bingo!
Dino DNA."
The prologue heavily suggests that it was
this mosquito — or rather, one like it — that
was later used by John Hammond and Sir Benjamin
Lockwood's company InGen to extract dinosaur
DNA and then create the T-rex in the 1980s.
By 1969, John Hammond had made his vested
interest in animals very clear, having opened
his first animal preserve, Animal Kingdom,
that year in Nairobi, Kenya.
He also hires future Jurassic Park employee
Robert Muldoon to work there as the park warden.
But taking care of and showcasing animals
already on the planet clearly isn't enough
for Hammond, and he soon sets out to bring
dinosaurs back into the modern world.
Having dreamed up the idea of using the DNA
of creatures encased in amber — like the
mosquito — to clone extinct animals, he
starts working with a small research team,
calling his company the Hammond Foundation.
In 1975, Hammond had secured enough investors
and a partnership with British entrepreneur
Sir Benjamin Lockwood.
Together they found International Genetic
Technologies, a bio-engineering company more
commonly referred to as InGen.
Working out of a laboratory in Lockwood's
basement, the pair teams up with scientists
and conducts research on bringing extinct
animals back to life.
Here, they make plans for a dinosaur theme
park, which they name Jurassic Park.
In 1982, InGen signs a 99-year-long lease
for Isla Sorna and the Muertes Archipelago
from the Costa Rican government, where they
plan to conduct research, and construction
begins on Jurassic Park: San Diego.
In 1984, almost a decade after founding InGen,
John Hammond and Sir Benjamin Lockwood have
their first major breakthrough.
Still working out of Lockwood's estate, he,
Hammond, and their team of scientists begin
a fertilization test on an artificial ovum,
which is successful.
A year later, they move their headquarters
to Palo Alto and successfully clone the prehistoric
DNA from the amber.
But other changes are afoot at InGen, as Hammond
suspends construction on Jurassic Park: San
Diego indefinitely.
Instead, he looks to move the park to Isla
Nublar in Costa Rica.
InGen leases the island from the Costa Rican
government, adding it to the 99-year lease
they'd already agreed to.
Now making use of the islands they leased,
InGen starts working on Isla Sorna, which
they call Site B — but they haven't been
able to clone a dinosaur yet, despite having
success with the amber.
In 1986, Hammond and Lockwood add Dr. Henry
Wu to their team, and he suggests they splice
the DNA of dinosaurs with that of modern animals
like frogs.
Shortly afterward, InGen successfully clones
their first dinosaur, a triceratops.
Wu also comes up with the lysine contingency,
a plan that would theoretically protect the
humans if the dinosaurs ever escaped.
By adding a faulty gene to the dinosaurs,
they'd become dependent on supplemental lysine
that InGen gave them.
Removing dinosaurs from captivity, then, would
deprive them of the enriched food, send the
dinosaurs into a coma, and ultimately kill
them.
Now seeing significant progress with its ability
to genetically engineer and replicate dinosaurs,
InGen goes ahead with plans for a new Jurassic
Park on Isla Nublar, which they refer to as
Site A. Construction begins on the island
in 1988 and is finished in 1993.
During this period, InGen successfully hatches
more dinosaurs, including the Tyrannosaurus
rex "Rexy," who is seen throughout the "Jurassic
Park" and "Jurassic World" movies.
Rexy is born on Site B but is moved over to
her paddock on Isla Nublar in 1989 when she's
one year old.
InGen has other innovative success thanks
to Dr. Henry Wu, who realizes that the DNA
of the yellow poison dart frog they've been
using is incompatible with some dinosaur genomes,
like velociraptors.
He suggests InGen uses the reed frog.
Although any geneticist should suspect that
since the reed frog can change sex, this ability
could be passed down to the dinosaurs, it's
ignored and is later the reason the dinosaurs
have been able to reproduce — a reveal seen
in "Jurassic Park" and expanded upon in "The
Lost World: Jurassic Park."
Wu also researches the hybridization of dinosaurs
during this period, which, of course, will
eventually lead to the Indominus Rex.
However, InGen also suffers a major blow when
Sir Benjamin Lockwood leaves the company after
he and John Hammond fall out.
Although the cause for this is not known in
"Jurassic Park", it's retconned into the story
in "Jurassic World: Dominion."
In this latest installment to the franchise,
we learn that Hammond was disgusted by Lockwood's
interest in using their research for human
cloning after his daughter, Charlotte, who
worked on Isla Sorna, revealed she wished
to have a baby this way.
"Just like Blue, Charlotte was able to have
a child all by herself.
She created you with her own DNA."
Despite Sir Benjamin Lockwood's departure
from InGen, John Hammond forges ahead with
his plan to open Jurassic Park on Isla Nublar.
However, the company's board of directors
has concerns about the park's safety after
gatekeeper Jophery Brown is killed by a Velociraptor
while transferring them to a higher security
holding pen and his family sues InGen.
Nevertheless, Hammond believes Jurassic Park
is the perfect place to bring his grandchildren,
Lex and Tim, to get their minds off their
parents' divorce.
Lawyer Donald Gennaro also heads to Isla Nublar
to assess the weaknesses of the park and whether
or not operations should be shut down before
the park even opens.
He brings along Dr. Ian Malcolm for another
expert opinion.
"Our scientists have done things which nobody
has ever done before."
"Yeah, but your scientists were so preoccupied
with whether or not they could but they didn't
stop to think if they should."
In response, Hammond invites Dr. Alan Grant
and Dr. Ellie Sattler along, hoping they will
endorse the park.
Elsewhere, Lewis Dodgson meets with Jurassic
Park computer programmer Dennis Nedry and
convinces him to steal dinosaur embryos for
rival company BioSyn in exchange for $1.5 million.
"The bottom screws open…
Its coolant is compartmentalized inside…"
On June 11, everyone arrives at the park,
and the events of the first "Jurassic Park"
film take place over the next 48 hours.
John Hammond takes Alan Grant, Ellie Sattler,
Ian Malcolm, and Donald Gennaro on a tour
of Jurassic Park where they see brachiosaurus
and parasaurolophus dinosaurs.
The group is later joined by Lex and Tim,
but they see very few other dinosaurs that afternoon.
An unexpected tropical storm heading toward
Isla Nublar then forces all non-essential
personnel to be evacuated, leaving only Nedry,
Hammond, Robert Muldoon, and Ray Arnold to
manage the park.
Nedry soon sneaks off to steal the embryos
and shuts down all power and security protocols
on the island, except for the velociraptor
holding pen.
This allows Rexy to escape her paddock and
attack Lex, Tim, Ian and Alan.
And Donald suffers one of the most memorable
deaths in cinema history.
The same goes for Nedry, who doesn't quite
make it off the island with all of his stolen
embryos thanks to a run-in with a spunky dilophosaurus.
In a bid to reverse Nedry's actions and get
the power back on, Ray does a full system
reset, but this deactivates the raptors' paddock.
It's not long before Ray and Robert are both
devoured by the raptors.
"Clever girl."
This leaves Alan, Ellie, Ian, Hammond, Lex,
and Tim to get the power back on and call
for help.
They eventually do do this, but they encounter
the raptors several more times before being
saved by Rexy.
By the end of the film, even John concurs
Jurassic Park can't be saved, and the survivors
escape in a helicopter.
"The Lost World: Jurassic Park" begins by
filling in the gaps of the past four years
since InGen abandoned Isla Nublar.
During this period, the bioengineering company
is hit with more lawsuits for the wrongful
deaths of Donald Gennaro, Robert Muldoon,
and Ray Arnold, which they covered up, and
are nearly bankrupt because of it.
Because of this, John Hammond is fired by
the board, and his nephew, Peter Ludlow, replaces
him as CEO.
He makes plans to open Jurassic Park: San
Diego and wants to move over dinosaurs from
Site B. There are plenty because as Dr. Henry
Wu discovered, the lysine contingency had
proven ineffective and the remaining dinosaurs
began breeding.
Dr. Ian Malcolm breaks his non-disclosure
agreement with InGen to raise awareness over
the events on Isla Nublar, but is discredited
by Ludlow.
Despite this, he initially refuses Hammond's
request for him to go to Site B with a small
group of experts and document the dinosaurs
there and stop InGen from profiting off them.
However, he changes his mind when his girlfriend,
Dr. Sarah Harding, is part of the group and
already on the island.
He follows her there to "rescue" her but soon
discovers his teenage daughter Kelly has stowed
away on the rescue mission, too.
Hammond's team, the "Gatherers," race against
InGen's "Hunters" but are ultimately forced
to work together after freed dinosaurs and
a pair of rexes destroy their vehicles and
communication equipment.
After several encounters with the buck rex,
his female counterpart, and some velociraptors,
the Gatherers escape the island, but Ludlow's
men capture the buck and take him to San Diego.
Ian and Sarah use the young T. rex, "Junior,"
to lure him back onto the cargo ship.
The ship sails back to Isla Sorna, but not
before Junior eats Ludlow.
Following the events on Isla Sorna and in
San Diego, John Hammond petitions the government
to have Isla Sorna left as a nature reserve
for the dinosaurs.
The U.S. House Committee of Science also passes
the Gene Guard Act, which gives bioengineered
dinosaurs the same status and rights as endangered
species.
As a result, access to the islands is restricted
and InGen is forbidden from cloning any other
prehistoric flora or fauna.
This seems to be the end of InGen's Jurassic
adventure.
But when Hammond dies shortly after the events
of Lost World, Masrani Global swoops in and
acquires the bioengineering firm.
Having taken over from his father as the CEO
of Masrani Global in 1992, Simon Masrani has
kept a watchful eye over Hammond's company
for years.
After taking over InGen in 1998, Masrani sets
out to fulfill Hammond's failed dream of opening
Jurassic Park, this time renamed Jurassic
World.
Breaking the Gene Guard Act, he starts experimenting
mere months after Hammond's death.
Shortly after, InGen begins secret experiments
on Site B with the goal of illegally breeding
new species, including the superpredator spinosaurus.
Plans for a new park are underway, and in
1999, the U.N. grants Masrani Global legal
— but limited — access to Isla Sorna.
Simon brings Dr. Henry Wu into his new "Jurassic
World" project in 2000 — who eventually
becomes the lead genetic biologist at InGen.
"Jurassic Park III" begins by revealing what
Alan Grant and Ellie Sattler have been doing
in the eight years since they were on Isla
Nublar.
Notably, Ellie has retired from paleobotany.
Although the two remain close, Ellie is now
married to Mark Degler, who works at the state
department, and they have two young children
together.
Meanwhile, Alan remains active in the field
of paleontology.
In the beginning of the film, we see him and
his protégé, Billy Brennan, testing the
prototype of a machine that's able to craft
an accurate replica of a velociraptor voice box.
"Wow…this is brilliant, Billy."
It's here at this worksite that wealthy thrill-seeking
couple Paul and Amanda Kirby approach Alan
and offer to fund further research if he gives
them — and three mercenaries — an aerial
tour of Isla Nublar.
Alan reluctantly agrees, and brings Billy
along with him.
But the Kirbys' ulterior motive is soon revealed,
as the couple actually plans to rescue their
son, Eric, who — along with Amanda's boyfriend,
Ben Hildebrand — has gone missing on Isla
Sorna after an illegal parasailing tour over
the island.
On the island, Alan finds Eric, now the sole
survivor, and reunites him with his parents.
Their group faces attacks from velociraptors,
pteranodons, and the spinosaurus, and all
three of the mercenaries are killed one by
one.
Alan gets out a distress call to Ellie and
Mark, though, who send a rescue team while
Alan fakes a distress call with his raptor
voice box to help them escape.
Billy, believed to be dead, is later rescued
by the U.S. Marines.
As a result of Alan and the Kirbys' actions
on Isla Sorna, a group of pteranodons escape
and are spotted over British Columbia.
However, Simon Masrani hires security contractor
Vic Hoskins to deal with them; after doing
this, he is subsequently hired as InGen's
head of security.
These events hadn't put Masrani off opening
his new park, Jurassic World, and in 2002
— a year after Alan's harrowing visit to
Isla Sorna — Masrani announces his plans
to the world.
He also has Rexy and other rogue dinosaurs
recaptured on Isla Nublar.
They are shipped to Site B until their enclosures
in the new park are finished.
In 2003, InGen bribes members of the U.S.
House Committee of Science, who then agree
to remove the restrictions on InGen because
of the Gene Guard Act, which allows them to
begin cloning and genetically engineering
new species of dinosaurs for Jurassic World.
The following year, Simon Masrani hires Claire
Dearing as an intern on the Jurassic World project.
Masrani Global Corporation soon begins moving
the dinosaurs back from Site B to the new
park on Site A. At the time, Masrani's company
is credited with saving the creatures from
ecological disaster.
It's later revealed in 2015 that the strain
on the Isla Sorna ecosystem had actually been
caused by InGen's secret experiments on Isla
Sorna in 1998 when Masrani acquired the company.
In 2005, Simon Masrani's company opens its
new dinosaur park, Jurassic World, to the public.
Elsewhere, just a few short years later, Sir
Benjamin Lockwood's daughter, Charlotte, has
succeeded in cloning herself.
Her daughter, Maisie, is born.
While Charlotte suffers from a rare genetic
disease that leads to her death in 2009, Claire
continues rising through the ranks of InGen.
She eventually becomes the senior assets manager
at Jurassic World.
"We've learned more from genetics in the past
decade than a century of digging up bones."
Work on the Indominus rex begins in 2012 after
demands from Jurassic World's board of investors
cause Claire and Masrani to ask Dr. Henry
Wu to create a hybrid theropod.
Developments in dinosaur behavior at Jurassic
World continue, with Owen Grady selected to
head up a special project as its head velociraptor
trainer.
"Delta, I see you.
Back up."
During this time, Masrani authorizes the construction
of a new facility in Siberia in 2012, which
opens in 2014.
Its focus is to extract the DNA of animals
from the Ice Age.
On Isla Nublar in 2012, a new pack of velociraptors
is engineered by Wu's team, and the raptors
Blue, Charlie, Delta, and Echo are born.
In 2013, Owen recognizes some nuances in the
dynamic of their pack and requests that his
friend Barry Sembène join his team.
By 2015, Jurassic World has operated for 10
years without incident.
In 2015, Simon Masrani publicly announces
that Jurassic World will soon be unveiling
a new genetically engineered dinosaur: the
Indominus rex.
"It tried to break the glass."
"I like her spirit."
As a result, ticket sales rise astronomically.
Meanwhile, Claire Dearing's nephews, Zach
and Gray Mitchell, come to visit her on Isla
Nublar while their parents go through divorce
proceedings.
Their arrival coincides with Jurassic World's
first big disaster.
The Indominus rex, which ate its twin when
it was younger, is much smarter than InGen
scientists expected and displays traits that
even Dr. Henry Wu, its creator, is surprised by.
Its camouflage abilities, along with its significant
intelligence, allow it to escape.
In its ensuing rampage, it nearly kills Owen,
and its carnage throughout the park causes
mass chaos, destruction, and further dinosaur
escapes.
Claire and Owen team up to search for Zach
and Gray, who briefly encounter the indominus
on their Gyrosphere ride.
Meanwhile, the pteranodons escape their enclosure
when Masrani's helicopter sends the Indominus
rex into the paddock.
He dies when pteranodons and dimorphodons
fly into the helicopter and it crashes.
Then, realizing that extreme measures need
to be taken, Owen uses Blue's pack to hunt
the indominus.
"Your boyfriend's a badass."
To his and the others' dismay, they initially
side with her, sensing her velociraptor DNA.
However, Owen eventually gets through to Blue,
and she helps them fight the indominus.
With the help of Rexy and a surprise assist
from the mosasaurus, the group defeats the Indominus.
Despite a lot of deaths, all's well that ends
well; Zach and Grey's parents return to get
them together, seemingly no longer getting
divorced, while Claire and Owen walk off into
the sunset.
Season 1 of "Jurassic World: Camp Cretaceous"
takes place simultaneously to the events of
"Jurassic World," beginning just before Jack
and Gray arrive on Isla Nublar.
A group of six kids — Darius, Ben, Yaz,
Brooklynn, Kenji, and Sammy — arrive on
the island to attend adventure camp.
However, they discover problems within the
park and end up having several close encounters
with dinosaurs like the carnotaurus.
However, before their many near-death experiences,
Claire Dearing actually planned for her nephews
to attend this camp, but their counselor Roxie
suggests that it would be too much to take on.
As Season 1 progresses, the campers are attacked
by the Indominus rex and the mosasaurus, which
makes them miss the ferry off Isla Nublar,
leaving them stranded on the island.
Season 2 picks up after the events of "Jurassic
World," with the island now all but abandoned.
While trying to avoid getting killed by dinosaurs,
the kids face off against new characters Mitch
and Tiff, who have come to the island claiming
to be eco-tourists, but instead are hunters
looking to bag some dinosaur trophies.
Of course, they both get what's coming to
them, with Rexy taking a bite out of Mitch
and Tiff being killed by the baryonyx duo
"Chaos" and "Limbo."
"Jurassic World: Camp Cretaceous" Season 3
lines up with the opening scene of "Jurassic
World: Fallen Kingdom," which is set six months
after the events of "Jurassic World."
Dr. Henry Wu has just started working for
Sir Benjamin Lockwood's estate manager, Eli
Mills, and they've sent a group of mercenaries
to recover the bones of Indominus rex.
The animated series recreates pieces of this
opening scene before depicting what else was
going on around the island.
It notably reveals that Wu engineered two
types of hybrid dinosaurs.
He created the Scorpios rex before the Indominus,
but Simon Masrani ordered Wu to have her killed
because she was too terrifying for the park.
However, he didn't do this, instead placing
the dinosaur into a cryofreeze chamber and
planning to use her to create his next hybrid.
She is accidentally freed at the end of Season
2, and after asexually procreating between
the second and third seasons, she and her
child attack the campers several times.
They face off against the campers for the
last time in the old Jurassic Park Visitors
Center in the episode "Escape from Isla Nublar,"
where the dinosaurs are killed when the roof
caves in.
Afterward, in Season 4, the campers finally
escape from Isla Nublar.
Back on the mainland, Wu receives the Indominus
rex DNA the mercenaries recovered from Isla
Nublar and engineers a new dinosaur called
the Indoraptor.
The following year, Claire Dearing founds
the Dinosaur Protection Group after Isla Nublar's
volcano Mount Sibo becomes active and threatens
to kill all the dinosaurs.
In June 2018, Claire Dearing is summoned to
Sir Benjamin Lockwood's estate, where he introduces
himself as an old associate of John Hammond's.
He offers to fund her rescue mission to Isla
Nublar so that she can save the dinosaurs
from extinction as Mount Sibo is now erupting.
However, he requests that her now ex-boyfriend
Owen Grady also join the mission, as he's
the only one who can save Blue.
"Back for more, huh?"
"Can I buy you a beer?"
"Did you bring em or do we gotta like go somewhere?"
Claire and Owen return to the island along
with paleoveterinarian Zia Rodriquez and IT
expert Franklin Webb.
To their surprise, they are met by mercenary
and trophy hunter Ken Wheatley, who double-crosses
them and captures Blue.
After a few close encounters with dinosaurs
and a near-drowning, Claire, Owen, Zia, and
Franklin escape the island and stow away onboard
one of Wheatley's ships, where they are taken
back to the Lockwood estate.
Benjamin has just died at the hands of Eli
Mills — who has subsequently taken control,
locking Lockwood's granddaughter Maisie in
her room and going ahead with his plans to
bankroll further genetic research.
Claire and Owen discover that Dr. Wu has created
a new hybrid called the Indoraptor.
Furthermore, Mills is auctioning off dinosaurs
to the highest bidder.
But in typical Jurassic fashion, this deadly
dinosaur doesn't remain in its cage for long
and kills several of the guests before attacking
Maisie.
With a little help from Blue, Claire, Owen,
and Maisie eventually trick the Indoraptor
so it falls through the glass roof and impales
itself.
Mills is killed in the chaos at the mansion.
But when the group is faced with gas potentially
killing all the dinosaurs within the mansion,
Maisie makes the choice to let them all go
free.
"I had to.
They're alive like me."
One year after "Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom,"
dinosaurs have spread across North America
and humans begin to encounter them more and
more — and it's not long before they spread
across the entire world.
This is shown in the short film "Battle at
Big Rock," which gives viewers an insight
into what this new world looks like.
Centered around one family of campers at Big
Rock National Park, it begins when a mother
and baby nasutoceratops wanders around their
campfire.
The human family joins the nasutoceratops
mother and her mate in the fight against the
allosaurus, and it eventually leaves when
the young daughter shoots it with a crossbow.
The film depicts just one of the many encounters
humans now have with dinosaurs and is a precursor
to what comes in "Jurassic World: Dominion."
But before the epic finale can take place,
the "Jurassic Park" timeline jumps over to
the campers on Mantah Corp Island.
Season 5 of "Jurassic Park: Camp Cretaceous"
leads directly into the third "Jurassic World"
film, re-establishing Lewis Dodgson's character.
Voiced by Adam Harrington in the animated
series and played by Campbell Scott in "Dominion,"
the CEO of BioSyn is the main antagonist for
the remainder of the franchise.
Although the campers foil his attempt to use
mind control chips on all the dinosaurs on
the island, he gets away with the technology,
which will soon come into play.
Ellie Sattler and Alan Grant reunite in "Jurassic
World: Dominion" as Lewis Dodgson invites
them to tour his BioSyn facility, where Ian
Malcolm now works.
With help from Ian and Ramsay Cole, they quickly
discover that Dodgson and Henry Wu have been
genetically engineering a swarm of prehistoric
giant locusts to destroy all crops except
the ones grown with BioSyn seeds.
However, Wu needs Maisie Lockwood's DNA to
fix a genetic defect in the locusts, so Dodgson
has her and Blue's child, Beta, kidnapped
from the Sierra Nevada Mountains.
"Claire!
They found her!"
"What?
Who are they?"
"Poachers.
I've seen em around."
Claire and Owen mount a rescue mission to
save them, tracking them to Malta, where they
meet cargo pilot Kayla Watts, who agrees to
fly them to the BioSyn facility in the Dolomites.
Inside the facility, Ellie, Alan, Ian, and
Ramsay help Maisie escape and steal a locust
sample in the process.
Maisie reunites with her parents and introduces
them to the "Jurassic Park" legends.
"Dr. Grant?
Here you are.
I'm Owen Grady.
Big fan.
I read your book.
Well, book on tape."
To destroy evidence of his attempted crimes,
Dodgson sets fire to the locusts, but the
flames engulf the entire facility.
He is killed by three dilophosauruses before
he can escape.
However, he leaves the mind-controlled giganotosaurus
as a parting gift.
Thankfully, Rexy is there to save the day
alongside a therizinosaurus, and the group
then rescues Wu, who plans to stop the locusts.
Claire and Owen take Maisie home and reunite
Blue with Beta.
Meanwhile, Ellie and Alan get back together
and plan to go public about BioSyn.
The BioSyn Valley is declared a dinosaur sanctuary
by the United Nations, leaving the world with
the formidable task of coexisting with these
prehistoric animals.